[Musique]
ouvrier du bâtiment mort le 29 avril
2020 après avoir été exposé à une longue
période de travail sous des températures
atteignant les 38 degrés nous pensons à
Yann 34 ans agent de sécurité dans un
aéroport mort le 22 février 2020 après
avoir effectué son travail c'est-à-dire
assis dehors sous le soleil pendant des
heures vous savez pourquoi je suis venu
à vos émissions monsieur Hanouna parce
qu'on m'avait dit ce monsieur il vous
donne la possibilité de parler à tout le
monde voilà pourquoi j'y suis venu et
vous savez pourquoi mes amis vont
partout et pourquoi il n'est pas
question pour eux de boycotter tel ou
telle émission parce que ça voudrait
dire que les autres sont plus
respectables elles le sont souvent c'est
pas très difficile d'être plus
respectable que la vôtre et si vous vous
figurez qu'on vient vous voir par
sympathie pour vous je préfère vous dire
que vous vous trompez vous êtes des
organisateurs de spectacle et on se
faufile dans vos spectacles pour y
porter notre parole nous ne sommes pas
vos copains est-ce que la maman que vous
êtes est inquiète de le savoir dans cet
environnement à côté de ces noms dont on
attend entendu parler ces dernières
années
[Musique]